[音楽]
見てる
こんばんははじめしゃちょーです
きました心霊スポットです
はじめしゃちょー心霊スポット好きで結構
いろんな心霊スポット行ってきたんです
けれども今回は新潟県にある
廃墟に来ておりますはい
静岡から6時間かけてきました新潟の皆
さん
こんばんは
遠かったね絶対に聞こえない今回ですね
新潟県にある
昔
定番パークだった場所
海底のパークに来ておりますはい
遊園地ですね簡単に言ったら今その遊園地
が廃墟化してしまっていましてそちらに
今回来ております
その名もロシア村
ロシア村という名前の
心霊スポットですねその廃墟に結構撮影が
難しくて入っちゃダメとか結構多いんです
けど今回ちゃんと管理者の許可を取って
撮影に来ておりますもうねそこにあるん
ですけど早速見に行きましょうか
これです
[音楽]
一番上の
丸い部分が
カワチ
そこにキュートを感じてるんですねはい
ロシア村っていうテーマパークの中にです
ね教会がありましてそれももう廃墟化して
いますこちらですね
なのでテーマパークにある今回
廃協会に来てます
いやーはいテーマパークハイ遊園地とかっ
てめっちゃ怖くないなんかトンネルとか
そういう場所って何回も行ったことあるん
ですけどこういうなんか昔は楽しかったと
かなんかその
栄ってた時期のやつが廃れて廃墟になった
場所っていうのってなんかより一層怖い
聞いてから知ってまして結構ビビってます
今日こちらの教会ですねシューズなり教会
という名前の教会ですテーマパークだった
時にですねやっぱその
結婚式とかあげるじゃないですか
結婚式あげたりする場所だった教会が今
廃墟化して廃業界になってるという
そんな状態ですねなんかネットに情報ない
かな
協会に新潟
やっぱ
ネットで調べたら心霊スポットで出てき
ますね
ロシアとの異文化交流を目的に作られた
新潟ロシア村は
金
操り悪化
なんかいろいろうまくいかずに10年余り
で閉園でそのまま放置されてなんかテレビ
とかでも取り上げられる心霊スポットに
なってるらしいです
なんかあっちにさ別の建物のわかります
教会の他にもう一個奥にホテル棟っていう
丸いホテルというホテルがあそこにあるん
ですけどあそこ2009年に全焼してます
火災で
建物は残ってるんですけども結構中が
ボロボロだったりするんですけども一応
そこも今回許可を頂いて入れることになっ
てるので
なんか家事あったところのが怖いよね
入れるけどなんか最新の注意を払って
欲しいというお話をいただいているので
ちょっとこの教会とホテルを今回見に行っ
ていきたいと思いますやっぱなんかあれだ
ね昔はお祝いしててさ幸せいっぱいの
盛り上がってた場所が今こういう有様だっ
ていうのがすごい結構見ててなんかすごい
感じるものがあるらしいよ早速見ていき
ましょうかはいというわけで中に入る前に
ちょっと周り見てみましょうか
[音楽]
テーマパークっていうぐらいだからさ
やっぱ
昔は賑わってたんだろうね
[音楽]
今やなんか
全くその名残が
段ボールだ
おい佐川急便のダンボールがあるぞ
ソリッドスネークか
[音楽]
えここだってさ来るまでめっちゃ遠かった
んですよなんかちゃんと鍵で施錠されてて
立ち入り禁止ゾーンになってて人が来れ
ないはずなんですけども
なんか不法侵入者とかいそうだね
あここからご覧ください
ここ結構
怖いねー
教会ってちょっとなんか
怖さあるよね
ぐるっと回ってみましょうか
[拍手]
草が生い茂っててすごいことになってるな
まあ本当に手入れされてないんでしょうね
これ絶対何もない
絶対何もないわ戻ろう
だってもう全部これ草でしょ多分この先
いやー多分何もないと思いますそして
佇む教会
[音楽]
誰か覗いてないよね
本当に違うよね大丈夫だよねなんか白い
顔みたいなのが
違うよねなんか白いあるけど
[音楽]
ほら見ても鳥肌
怖いなぁ
[音楽]
やばい
怖い
これやだね
[音楽]
健介は今日どこまでついてきてくれるの
これは今日初めて中に入るよっていう
ところまで外
専門外専門です
[音楽]
一緒に行っちゃったらやっぱもううるさく
て壊れちゃいますよこの建物
なんかダメ
かな先っぽだけ先っぽで同じね
先っぽだけはちょっとだけちょっとだけ
先っぽだけでいいから本当にちょっとだけ
ちょっとだけ
じゃあちょっととりあえず教会の前まで
行ってみようと思います
足元こんな感じですもう
荒れてるなぁこういうコンクリートの階段
ってすごいもう壊れやすいんだろうな
何これ
なんか
鉄も
腐敗してるというか
鉄くずみたいなのがありますね
いやーボロボロ
[音楽]
見つけてよ」って書いてありますねこれ誰
か落書きしたんだろうね
よくね普通に懲らしめてやりたい
ねここは割と
開けてるスペースもありますね
ガソリンのタンクが置いてある
いやここは
燃やそうとしたのか何かをこれがホテル棟
ですね後で行こう
じゃあちょっとだけ中入ってみましょうか
いやーなんかもう壊れてるな天井とか
天井穴開いてるよもう
俺でも書けそうな落書き発見もうちょっと
これ
書くならできればやめてほしいけど
おいおいよしき
だめだろうこんなとこ書いちゃ
入ってみます
失礼します
ラックが気がすごい
まこちゃんとゆうちゃん6年目ですね
荒れてるねー
[音楽]
早速教会入ってみたいと思います
これ教会ですね
この広さ
天井とかもすげー
オリジナルでこいつこいつこいつこいつ
こいつこいつこいつ俺じゃない俺じゃない
行きましょうか
なんかさここで結婚式した人がいたって
思うとちょっと悲しくなるね
こういう状態
だった今ガサガサ多かった
いやこっちこっちこっちこっち
わかんない音が響いてるからかもしれない
けど
ほらほらほら
動いてる
釣ってみましょうか
[拍手]
怖い
誰ここでマーチングバンドの練習したやつ
絶対ここじゃないでしょマーチングバンド
だけは
[音楽]
確かに人は来ないかもしれないけどね
楽器の練習とか
いや俺こういうのちょっと怖いんだよね
わかる
なんかこういうさ
クロス書きまくってる落書きとかさ
ちょっと良くない感じしますねちょっと
登ってみます
[音楽]
ここ
なんでヘルメット置いてあるんだ
叩いてかぶってジャンケンポンしてたのか
なここで
なんかね意味深な
椅子が
置いてあります
[音楽]
見てもうなんか廃墟というよりなんか
破壊されたんじゃないかってぐらい
ボロボロになってる
椅子とかだってこんな壊れ方しないでしょ
放置してて絶対
誰かが出入りしたか
何かがあってこうなってる気はしますね
[音楽]
抜かれてるよこっち
ほら
壊されてるね
ひどいです
こことかもなんか
[音楽]
そんなに壊れるってぐらいかなり
壊れてるなんか
怖くない壊れ方
なんか穴
そんな高さまで生じで穴開けるのある
じゃんあれがすごい高さまでされてる感じ
あるんだよ
[音楽]
いやマジでわかんないすっごいボコボコ
じゃないんだってあ赤い
ちょっと
怖いです
大広間はこんな感じの大丈夫結構きつい
マジ怖いです
[音楽]
戻っちゃうここから俺一人で頑張る本当に
帰ってきてください
他の場所は行ってみましょうか
怒られるね本当にマジで怒られるってお前
何してるのよ何してんですかいや俺は
ちょっと許可取ってここ来たな
[音楽]
いつからいるのここができたときから
ここが栄えてる時からずっと
ですマジで怒られるというわけでですね
もう心霊スポット言ったらね結構彼と俺が
一緒にいると何かしらが起きる可能性高い
ので冷凍コンビと呼んでくださいここから
は彼とお届けしたいと思います
頑張ろうなはいお願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
新品のビニール傘
優しい人がいるんだなありがとうが
おかしいのよ絶対誰か
壁パンチしたもこことかも
パンチしたとかあります
[音楽]
怖いねでもこういうの
ちょっと怖いよ
[音楽]
聞こえるなんかこっちから音いや俺だけ
コツコツ
荒れてるね
大広間はだいたいこんな感じだと思います
けどどこかから地下と2階に行けるところ
があるんですよ
探してみようぜ
[拍手]
どうなってるのこれ
なんか水浸しなんだけどここ
どす黒い水が
めっちゃ溜まってますね
上もボロボロすごくないこれ
[音楽]
すごいいやこれ奥行けなそうだな
ぁ
怖い
マジで怖い
特に上に行けそうな場所はないです
ねなんかちょっと騒がしくない
ちょっと騒がしい見てみようぜ
んすけが
暴れてるだけだこっち行ってみようか
2階とか地下行ってみたいよね行ってみ
たいです
[音楽]
多分これがホテル棟につながる
階段そして廊下
これが多分地下に行けますね
[拍手]
いやー危ねえなこれ
これ
どっちから行きますまずは教会の中全部
みたいな行きましょうか
[音楽]
待ってやばい
怖い何これ
何これ
布団かななんか
布団とか服が調査なしてます
そんな古くなさそうじゃん
1000円ぐらいのレベルいやわかんない
布団がどれくらい色褪せないかわかんない
けどでもすっごい色がはっきりしてる
じゃん服の
これ
サービスしてくれる
はいこっちだね
こっちももう
めちゃくちゃ
荒れてますね
[音楽]
すごい
破壊されてるようなレベル本当に
[音楽]
こういうのが天井見てください
めっちゃ高いんですよ天井がコウモリいる
ね
[音楽]
ここは2015年の23時27分にパリピ
が切ってます
[音楽]
すごい
これ建物崩壊しないか不安になってきたの
ちょっと上げ方がすごいぞとかちょっと
怖くない結構怖い
です
結構も怖い
結構怖いだ
虫いた
怖いこれ
どっち行く待って待ってまた明日あるんだ
けどえ下あるんですか
やばいマジで怖い
結構やばい
怖い
やばい
[音楽]
ボロボロだ
大丈夫か大きくしたわ一番怖いですなんか
韓ドラの悪役みたいになったの
パクパクです
いや怖い
1周が怖いんだよ
濡れてる
行きます
[音楽]
火事があった場所だね
なんか見てる消火栓とかがもうボロボロに
なってる
待って
[音楽]
これ
心臓に行かないと本当に気がする
[音楽]
待ってやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばい
ちょっと待って本当にやばい
これ人の首だ
洗面所が完全に崩壊してるしここに
マネキンダメでしょ
これトイレ来たね
[音楽]
俺たちホテルと入ってます
ポテトの地下に今いる気がする
だって絶対火事であるもんねこんな感じ
そうです黒い方とか
行きましょうか
あとね床が
床が濡れすぎて本当に
マジで男らしくないこと言うとやだ
これやばくね
大丈夫か
ゆっくりゆっくり行こう
大丈夫
ステップバイステップバイステップ
なんか
いなくなった
めっちゃ虫いた今
何かな
今ねもういなくなっちゃったね虫が溢れ出
てきてました
帰りたい
結構俺も無理かも俺結構まずい
[音楽]
待って本当にやだ何ここ
これどこに繋がってるんだ何この空間
[音楽]
虫この空間すごいです
ねめっちゃ広いのに下見て
なんかもう
池ぐらいのレベルで水が
溜まってますね
ここから
奥はさすがに行けなそうな感じがしますね
機械ですか
[音楽]
これ外だな
あーでもほら上見て
やっぱホテル棟になってる気づいたら
ホテル棟の中にいましたね
結構きつくないの
大丈夫か
汗やばい俺も
まだこんなか戻ると言われても結構無理な
んだけどできれば外か
中から戻っていくこの先からです
もうこの水系がちょっとやだよね
怖すぎる本当に
怖い
何の部屋なんだろう
[音楽]
なんか意味がわからないものが非常に多い
どっちから来たっけね俺たちどっちから来
たっけ
そうだよね
となるとこっちで行きたくなっちゃう
[音楽]
とりあえず上に行ければ
階段室だ
いや怖いってー
[音楽]
普通に戻ろうこれ結構限界だいやもう
背中見たら伝わります
椅子を使って
いこう僕
が
ある
[音楽]
大丈夫か
致命的なさやばい音とかは感じないよね
まだ
心霊屋敷と比べると今のところそんなに
ここやばいわっていうのは感じないです
行くか行ってないよね
行ってないと思います
えなんかめっちゃ
湿気っていうか
暑くないですか
[音楽]
何この穴
えちょっと今日まずいまずい気をつけよう
めっちゃでかい
なるこれ危ないな
[音楽]
これ落ちたら戻ってくれないんじゃない
すごいでかいよ流れます
[音楽]
いやちょっとこれ
危ないなこれ
戻らへん
すごいなこっち行こうか
[音楽]
すごい
汗
緊張感がやばい
ね
[音楽]
見てここも崖みたいな
本当だ上に行くか下に行くかって迷ってた
ところの上から来たから俺たち多分下から
潜ってホテルとも見ちゃったんだ気づい
たらホテルと言ってて
ぐちゃぐちゃになってたのは家事があった
からなんだと思います
じゃあひとまず
なんか聞こえるね聞こえます
きっと教会の2回まだ見てないよね見て
ないです
じゃあ教会の2階も見ていきましょう
逆にこういう白いとこ怖いんだよ
[音楽]
ごめん思い出して
あ着きました
いやここも
怖えぞ
業界の上ですねなんか一周がすごいぞここ
なんかめっちゃ変な匂いしない
ここから
ここからこうやって
教会を見渡せるって感じです
いやきついいや怖い怖い
雷だらけだ
期限を大事にしてくれ戻ろうよ
[音楽]
わかったわかりました
いかがだったでしょうか
全部見たよね多分ほぼ全部見れたと思い
ます
教会の地下
教会の上大広間全焼してしまったホテルも
一通り見たと思います
廃墟ってこんな怖いんだ
[音楽]
なんか閉鎖感がすごい嫌だったねはいあと
全焼してたからなんか建物の何だろう
焼けた後とかがすごい
当時めっちゃ勝ちだったんだなっていうの
を感じてなんかいるのがつらかった
とっても
汗伝わる
[音楽]
伝わりますあの汗見てもらったら分かると
思うんですけど本当になんか精神的にきつ
かっ
た
背中やばいっす
湖
[音楽]
最後なんか
うんこみたいになってる
本当に怖いところでしたねあとコウモリ
持って来なかったですけど
無事に帰ってくることができたので
一待ちこういう場所ね勝手に来る人が多
いって感じの方も言ってたのでちゃんと
許可を取ってね不法侵入するとマジで逮捕
なので行く時はちょっと許可を取っていき
ましょうじゃあ
[音楽]